what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
players stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion
despite recent results we already got
the historic quadruple this season we
were investigated by a wave of FIFA the
FA in the Premier League I followed in
the footsteps of the greats
by leaving Southampton you think a card
is a dog i shagged me brothers miss all
right and that's all we need thank you
for coming in mr. Giggs Mickey it's
lagging good guy why did hurricane text
us to choose him in the backyard for a
crashing wood crime nothing to be scared
of Phil it's just a tent I'm not scared
this is me happy face
dander in welcome wunderbar
this must have taken you all weekend
yeah all again come in come in I thought
we'd have a casual day baking it's so
night it looks like a toilet say hello
remember me I'm asked and I am the
special one welcome to the Great British
baking down
while we're all optimistic when it comes
to a big game Spurs have a tendency to
be rather Spurs that's the word so I ask
myself if I were British and want to win
a trophy what would I do
so I organize a baking competition now
every competition is judges so I found
the most judgmental and also out of work
people that I know and to ensure that we
win I've had the boys practicing baking
for weeks now hopefully this works and
we should win because after all we are
the only team ready for this yeah we are
ready for this Oh guys have more
resources than I do
oh wow the purple spies have somehow
been impressive all season but something
tells me they will step up in defiance
just a fun day out he said no stress he
said all of a sudden I'm under a lot of
pressure to score all these pies come on
we need to go higher I fear we may have
reached our ceiling tottenham amazing a
tottenham cake which is pink and fun but
also crumbly and fragile but it's really
immensity we'll be making a perfect
Manchester tart but the literal cheerio
I'm having the finest maraschino
cherries brownie on a private jet well
just so happy to have you on our team
for their signature bake Manchester
United are making a huge mistake
seriously they think he's garden gnome
of a manager's better than me
[Music]
to be honest I really thought when we
hosted this competition that the other
clubs they had like little to no baking
experience but as it turns out they are
taking this very seriously so guys you
need to focus on the finish where did
the decorative Lancashire roses 9320 of
them come on put more pressure on it
Sloane
hmm these all appear to be top top
quality lawyer
I won't taste them because I know they
are not as good as the Chelsea buns I
made three times in force and last place
you you you and especially you PAH
you should all be disappointed fourth
place is nice take it from me it is the
same as a trophy okay but come on
Harry's ankle has been through so much
is there something for us baking
contributions okay fine whatever
hurricane you are hereby a member of the
most excellent Order of the baking
Empire hyeri's been awarded MBE
[Music]
[Music]
so how do we beat Liverpool on the pitch
[Music]
[Music]
now that we're out of the Champions
League we have plenty of time to watch
cartoons so make sure you subscribe
don't look at me bro I did my part if
you can walk alone